أنابيل يمكن أن تختار المشكلة
تبادل لإطلاق النار منذ أن كنت تعتقد أنك أ
مشكلة يا رسالتي كاملة
دق حول الشارع الخاص بك
إذا حدث مشروع القانون في أي وقت مضى
ازدهار العقارات الركوب يا له من أهمية
الترام أوريو والمكان الذي يعرفه
الديمقراطية البيضاء الآن أكياس مليئة بالشكر
لعدم وجود منشقة عرض icq
حسنًا السياق وهناك الفيديو
الهولندي على أن لديك ساق و te
رمي والعملية الديمقراطية لمدة عشرة
سنوات الآن
منذ وقت طويل للتفاح ديكتاتور "
الرئيس في أعرج المال إلى شيء
والمستوى وكانوا الإدارة
المزيد من الرخصة مع مجانية ونزيهة
الانتخابات وانتم الديموقراطيين
الدستور ونظام جديد
الحكم
ولكن كان هناك أيضًا الكثير من هذا التطبيق
المشاعر وهذا المحتوى مع
سوء إدارة يصبح حرا
مع ورنيش أو وظائف هناك الاقتصادية
أزمة وآخرها الاعتداء
قهوة لك
نصف crysis يوتيوب أو لي فريقي و
رجل شعبي جدا ل mantingh ل
تفكيك البرلمان وبوذا
بارك الله في عملية الديموقراطيين
ومن هو الإنسان بريدي الأبيض
حكيمها
الرئيس هل تود أن تكون حاسما
أو العملية الدستورية واختيار
رؤية لنظام ديمقراطي جديد
هذا هو أكثر مباشرة ويعتمد على
الانتخابات المحلية والتآمر آسف
هذا الحد الأقصى مثل ارتفاع لرؤية الناس
المزيد من الغش في الشوارع
حسنًا ما يوجد في الجرارين من المذكرة هو أن
العملية الديمقراطية في تونس
بغض النظر عن مدى خلل وظيفي غير فعال
وتدفق هذا كان هذا اختيار الفئة
كنموذج يحتذى به للديمقراطية في
المنطقة التي لعبها لارس إن
الديكتاتوريات
هذا منع أو شيء من هذا القبيل وأرسلوا إلى المدنية
الحرب وخلق نظام جديد
الحكم وأين كانت الضوابط
والتوازنات كانت بالفعل زيتية بالنسبة لنا
حساب مضمون